table. Yes. And we had a nice
>> and the wind was blowing everything.
>> That's true. Except you cuz you're too
big for the wind to you're too big for
the wind to blow you,
>> you know, because I had a diabetes.
That's how I realized I put the weight
on, you know. But thank God.
>> Now I'm using the OMIC and it's good.
It's helping me lose weight now. It's
good.
>> Oh, okay. So, you're losing weight?
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's a You know,
Ompic. You heard of it? Ompic? No, not
really.
>> Is a from doctor, you know, OMI can
Yeah, you can use it for losing weight.
It's very good. Very good.
>> Is it healthy thing?
>> Yeah, it's very good, man. It's very
good.
>> Anyway, listen, bro.
>> Huh?
>> When are you going to become Muslim?
>> Listen, bro. I I something I never been
able to answer it. When Muhammad
went to King Najashi
and they protect him and they gave him a
good welcome,
why when he went back to Mecca, he said,
"I'm going to charge you jizzy attacks
and I'm going to kick you out of Arabian
Peninsula, bro." How it makes sense to
you never peninsula. What are you
talking about?
Okay, we know in hadith uh
never came to the Arab Peninsula. Okay,
I know
became what they call a Muslim and the
messenger of Allaham
prayed over him.
>> Yes, I know it's in hadith. I know. I
know. But my problem,
>> you have many problems in your life. If
you need there someone to help you with
your problems, go to the mosque and pray
to Allah.
>> Sham shamsi. Now when Muhammad went back
to Mecca,
>> was Muhammad is Muhammad or Muhammad?
>> Muhammad when he went back to Mecca.
>> He went back to Mecca. Yes.
>> And then he made the hijra to Medina
later.
>> Yes.
>> But why, bro? Why Quran 9:29? you such a
discrimination tax that we have to pay
jizar why
>> okay so the verse you're talking about
is in the Quran when Allah
command the believers to fight against
the Christians and the Jews and then
>> thank you bro remember that doesn't make
sense
>> listen when you read the verse clearly
firstly if you study history very well
who started the war against prophet
Muhammad wasallam are the Christians
because at that time either you are
under allow me to finish now either you
are under Christian Empire which was the
Byzantine okay the the the the or you
are under the Persian Empire both these
two empires started the war against the
prophetam
that's why the messenger of Allah
wasallam start the war and if you having
a problem allow me to finish if you're
having problem with this which is is
based upon justice, then you kind you're
going to you're going to have problem
with your own Bible because in the Bible
in Deuteronomy, it says God said to the
Israel, to the Jewish people to to the
Israelites to go and besiege a village,
if you besieged them and they surrender
that to you and alive the woman, the the
woman, the man and keep the children and
take their h their belongings. So now
clearly God is commanding the Israelite
to go out and fight innocent people and
besiege people and take the and kill an
analive a woman and a man. Do you have
follow this passage in the Old
Testament?
>> Okay. Are you talking about a a
Malachite?
>> No. No Malikite. No, it's not Malachite
at all.
>> Uh what there was one other one or two
other? Yeah. But yeah, this was uh this
wasn't good. This wasn't good. Right.
>> So God so God was wrong for commanding
the Israelites to go and besiege people.
So your God is evil.
>> Okay. Did Amalachites help?
>> No. No. Before Malachite, you said it's
not good. So it was bad. So your God
command with bad things.
>> Okay. Did Amalachites help them?
>> No. Before Malachite go back to you said
this was not good even though God
commanded it. So therefore, if it's not
good, it must be what? Bad.
>> Okay, Shamzi, let me ask you this. Did
the Amalachites help them first?
>> No, no, no, no. Before the Amalachites,
let's go back to what you said, Rob. You
said it is not good what God did in
Deuteronomy by commanding the Israelites
to besiege a city and analy woman and a
man. You said it's not good. So if it's
not good, what it means bad.
Okay, look, we know from Bible because I
know that. Yeah.
>> No, no, no, no. I'm going to allow you
to to finish because why? I want to go
back to what you said. You said it's not
good. Correct.
>> Look, if if you are
>> No, no, no. Before if you are or if you
he before all of this, Rob, for us to
continue healthy and respectful
discussion, tell me. So, when you said
is not good, what does it mean? The
opposite of the ocean is not good. It's
what? It's bad.
>> Look, bro. Every question
>> ask my question. If it's not good, it
must be bad. Correct.
>> I don't like killing babies.
>> Go get Okay. So, are you God said to do
it? So, is it good or bad? Only God said
to do it.
>> This was a judgment from him.
>> Yeah. Of course, I didn't tell you it
was judgment from Michael Jackson. I
know it's from him. But was it good or
bad?
Well, look, I I
wouldn't do it.
>> But it if it was just a oneoff incident
for a judgment from God,
>> Rob Rob just answer my question. Listen
to my question. When God said you said
it's not good and you don't like it, so
therefore is bad. If it's not good, it's
bad. Is it bad or not? Just answer my
question. Is it bad or not? When God
said to kill an unal alive woman and
children,
>> it's bad for that tribe.
>> So it's bad. So your God command that
which is bad.
>> But God has this authority.
>> So God, so your God tells people to do
bad things.
If it if you want to say baby,
Allah says Allah command only with
justice
with goodness. You know, so you trying
to speak against our beloved prophet
Muhammad
when you look back to his history, he
never started h uh oppressing people or
even he say clearly in the hadith in the
war in a war you know do not kill women
children in a war okay and likewise do
not cut off trees but in your Bible is
full of unaliving children women and you
have no problem to believe the Bible to
be the word of God. And by the way, when
God said that in the Old Testament was
that Jesus saying that
Jesus would have would have been he
would have known about that. He would he
would have been he would have had
knowledge of it, you know.
>> But so when God said when God said to
analy woman, was that Jesus or another
God?
Bro, this was a judgment of God.
>> I didn't tell you it was judgment from
Michael Jackson or I'm telling you was
that when when God said to do it, was
that Jesus? Was it Jesus?
>> Why Muhammad double crossed?
>> Muhammad, let me ask you, when God in
the Bible said to an alive children and
women, was that Jesus or another God?
Because you believe Jesus is God. So
therefore,
>> okay, bro, listen. If I'm honest, it's
very harsh. If I'm honest, it's very
harsh.
>> That was not my question. If it's very
harsh or soft. Was that a Jesus that
said to kill women and children?
>> Well, yes, it must have been obviously.
>> So Jesus loving then.
>> This was a one-off judgment.
>> I'm not asking you. It was brother. I'm
asking it was a football match. I know
it's judgment. I'm asking you cuz you
people drive us crazy by saying Jesus is
all loving. God is all loving, loves
everyone. So, and it's only good but
according to your Bible and according to
your robe, look, he's struggling to to
defend your religion because that is not
the teaching of God to command people to
kill children for no reason. Literally,
there was no reason.
>> How many,
>> bro? How many baby died uh was un alive
outside Noah's ark
>> outside your house?
>> Noah's ark. Noah Noah
>> Noah Noah's ark then it's clearly to
answer. Prophet Muhammad wasallam taught
us in the hadith when there's a lot of
evil okay Allah will do earthquake and
the people will die. Some people no wait
let me finish. The people that would die
the children will believe they'll go to
paradise. However, the children in
Islam, hear me out,
>> no in Islam,
>> hear me out. Let me out. The children,
hear me out. Hear me out. Okay, hear me
out. The children of the people of Noah
in the Quran, Allah said every time
generation will come out generation,
they will become more evil and more
greater evil. So Allah never told or
Allah never told Noah to go and alive
children. So don't compare the the
punishment of Allah upon the people of
Noah to your Bible when God said to
Allah children for no reason. He never
said because they're going to grow up as
an evil people. He never said that.
>> Did those babies drown outside Noah's
ark?
>> Yeah. Because they're going to grow up
as an evil people, disbelievers. Allah
mentioned that in the Quran.
>> Oh, like a kid in Islam.
>> Like one sense. Well said. You say see
Islam makes sense. But now according to
the Bible when God said to go and
besiege a city and analy for example
when God in Leviticus said to analy a
woman do you know why go on
>> he said because go he said to Moses go
kill every woman that slept with a man.
Imagine the crime of this woman because
she's married you go and kill her. It's
in your Bible. So you God was not happy
for a woman that was married. So he
asked Moses to go and kill every woman
that was married.
>> Yeah. It look uh Chamzy Old Testament
become Muslim.
>> The Old Testament look the Old Testament
is very harsh. But in Quran 29
if you believe in the Bible to be harsh.
Okay? So you of course punishment is
harsh. But we're not talking about being
harsh or not. Is it just or unjust?
>> If I become a Muslim, I have to accept
Bible.
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no way.
where in the Quran says believe in the
the John and Mark and Luke and and and
the Old Testament doesn't say that
>> Quran 29:46
Rob let's go
>> 2946 step by step Rob when God said when
God commanded with those e harsh
punishment of course from the nature of
punishment to be harsh that's why it's a
punishment so what does it say Quran 29
to finish robot said to do it was that
just or unjust
For what? For what?
>> When When God said to kill a woman
because she was married, is that just or
unjust?
>> I have to go back and look at context.
>> Here, I get it for you. Here, I have the
Bible here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Remind me. Remind me.
>> Go to You can check it from your phone.
It's in Leviticus when he says, "And you
know, it says keep the young girls for
yourself." So, you kill the the the
women that are married and you keep the
young girls. Why God is saying to keep
the little girls? Another translation to
do what? To play football with them.
>> As a maid. As a maid.
>> No, no, no, no. As a don't say as a
maid. Okay. Because a woman who are
married, you can make them maid too.
>> Yeah. Don't forget Quran 4:24me slaves.
>> The Quran does not say women who are
married. Stop lying. The Quran doesn't
say
>> Quran 236 and uh 424, bro.
>> Yeah. Just say numbers like the Just
going to help you. The Quran does not
command with evil.
>> Quran says you can take slave, bro.
>> Look, the brother, please, bro, you need
to read Quran.
>> Read numbers. I read Quran more than
you, brother. I mean, if I know the
Bible better than you, it's more so I
know the Quran better than you.
>> Was God very harsh in Old Testament?
Yes.
>> No, no, no, no. Of course, the punish
from the nature of punishment to be
harsh. The question was God just or an
just when he ordered the king of
children and women who serve to the men.
>> Those tribes used to sacrifice their
babies to the gods.
>> No, it doesn't say that. He never said
to in doesn't say that.
>> It he it he does say that in Old
Testament.
>> No, it doesn't. Different tri. They used
to put their baby in in in sacrifice to
>> other gods. Rob, stop wasting our time.
Just let us stick to to the the numbers.
Okay. Here.
>> Yeah. Bring it, bro. Bring it. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. One second. Get it.
>> 31. This is better than speaker's
corner.
>> Yeah. Enjoy yourself. Yeah. But
hopefully take it more serious because
ah listen why? Cuz I'm holding my phone.
Okay. We have here judges
here numbers. Okay. 31. and the brother
of course before I have it here my 31
uh yeah here look here look subhah uh I
need to turn the light okay
uh now therefore kill every mo among the
little ones and kill
every mo among the little ones and kill
every woman who has known a man okay but
keep life for yourselves all the young
girls who have not known a man. Okay. So
here in the Bible if you read you can
read the whole context. What I will say
to you Rob. Yeah. Let us go back to my
point. So when God said to kill babies
when uh to analy uh uh babies and
children and women and you know uh all
of this was that just from God or
unjust? That's my question.
>> Okay. The Sahabas.
>> No, no. Ask about Sahaba.
>> No, no, no. I'm gonna answer the angels.
Sahaba, they're not God, by the way.
Okay.
>> Sahabas
are not God. Answer my question.
>> Sahaba, they said to Rob, you know, ask
my question, Rob, be honest. In the
Bible, I'm answering it.
>> No, no. When God said in the Bible to
kill women and children and and analy a
lot of people, was that just or unjust?
Muhammad allowed it.
>> All right. You're lying against allowed.
No, no, no, no. That there's haditham
said when you go to war, do not kill
women. Do not kill children. You're
talking about Sahaba who went to war and
it was night when they wake up in the
morning they found out when they
attacked city night.
Yes. Clearly said do not kill children.
What he said is from them mean you
cannot he couldn't escape them because
he didn't know but however prophet never
commanded it never told people to do it
it was an accident you bible said to do
it clearly so don't try to guess
like I take care of yourself
I was going tell what my
What happened? Did I miss something?
Restart. Okay, I'm going to restart
again.